[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVID MILLER: There are more
people on earth every day.
And they all need to be fed.
This means we have to increase
the amount of agricultural
production on the planet.
But it also means that we have
to increase the nitrogen
fertilizers that
are being used.
This is leading to much larger
emissions of gases such as
nitrous oxide into
the atmosphere.
My name is David Miller, and
I'm helping to coordinate a
student-led independent
project.
Our team of nine engineering
graduate students are working
to develop and deploy fast,
compact, and low-power sensors
based on a new technology,
mid-infrared lasers.
The main goal of MIRTHE is to
build the next generation of
environmental sensors.
As part of MIRTHE's interest in
new ideas and applications,
the center provided a first-time
opportunity for
students to lead and manage
a fully funded
field research project.
MIRTHE and it's director,
Professor Claire Gmachl were
extremely supportive of us.
We design and engineer our
sensors so that the laser can
trace a long path to increase
the sensitivity of our
measurements.
To do this, we bounce the laser
many times between two
mirrors, which is known as
a multipass optical cell.
So this is a mid-infrared
laser, the
quantum cascade laser.
The beam comes out through
a lens here.
The beam is directed by these
mirrors through this hole,
into the sampling cell,
where the beam
passes multiple times.
The exit beam again goes
through the hole.
And it's focused right
onto the detector.
We can see signals from nitrous
oxide, acetylene, and
carbon monoxide.
Many kinds of human activities
lead to the emissions of both
greenhouse gases and
air pollutants.
We need to understand their
impacts on both climate and
air quality.
We took our sensors into the
field, to a location between
Washington, DC and Baltimore:
Beltsville, Maryland, where
there are both agricultural
and urban activities.
So we compared our measurements
with the typical
method, collaborating with the
scientists from the USDA.
We were really surprised that it
worked the first time out.
Normally, when you're working
with sensors, the first time
it doesn't work out
right away.
This is exactly the engineering
process.
You know you have a problem to
solve, but you don't know
exactly how.
So you try something.
And even if it fails, you can
usually see what it takes to
make it work.
We hope that one day our
sensors will be able to
measure trace gases on a large
scale, so that people
everywhere can understand
their effects on the
atmosphere.
[MUSIC PLAYING]